>>Narrator: Redwood Middle School
in Napa, California looks a lot
like every other middle
school in the country,
except for one extraordinary
classroom disguised as a spacecraft.
>>Teacher: Ladies and gentlemen,
I am receiving a call from Earth.
Yes, Earth, come in.
>>Narrator: In her
popular art elective,
Sharon Campbell lets her class
experience everything from physics
to physical fitness in an environment
that is out-of-this-world.
>>Sharon: So we have
decided that we are going
to land close to the south polar cap.
>>When I did my master's program,
I did it in classroom environments,
and I meant the physical
environments,
because I believe a classroom is
the largest tool you have to teach.
The color of an environment
is extremely important,
and I chose the colors of blue and
purple because it's very relaxing.
All of our classrooms are beige.
What kid or what adult ever
wanted to live in a beige world?
>>Sharon: Temperatures will range
between 70 degrees and negative 230.
Yes.
>>What I've done is I've imbedded
science, math and history,
as well as geography in my class
and made it a hands-on experience.
>>Sharon: Anyone find
proof of manufacturing?
>>So those kinetic
learners that we have,
those that are having
difficulty in their other classes,
they get to actually touch
and feel, manipulate,
analyze and build in this class.
>>Sharon: Did you find
proof of an herbivore?
>>This one, because it
doesn't have that sharp teeth.
They're not that sharp.
>>They can use the information they
got in theory in their other classes
and actually put it into a
real-life experience in this class.
>>Boy: I found hieroglyphics,
and I found out what it said.
>>Narrator: Campbell's
students learn a dynamic lesson
in ecology during every minute
of her class, pedaling a bicycle
that generates electricity
for the classroom.
>>Sharon: I've always said that
if I could just harness the power
and the energy in these 12-year-old
boys that I could run a city.
Well, we built a kid-power bike.
>>Narrator: With more than 14,000
dollars of her own money, Campbell
and her husband connected a wind
turbine to a set of batteries
to create a mini-plant that
generates power and passion.
>>Sharon: And we found
that 15 minutes
of cycling stores enough energy
to run the classroom for an hour.
I wanted to somehow be able to have
the kids experience what energy is.
They pedal that bicycle.
They understand now that motion
can be changed into electricity,
and when they understand that they
have the power to make energy,
then it's real easy to say, "You
have the power to save energy.
You have the power to
change the environment."
This is all about giving
power to the students.
>>People want to get on the bike.
There's a list.
>>There's usually a line of 10
people that want to get on the bike.
Right when you get in,
everyone runs to the bike.
>>Yeah, because it's
just riding a bike, but--
>> It's really cool to
be conserving energy
and saving energy for your class.
>>Sharon: Get ready.
Put down your shields.
Ladies and gentlemen, we
are going to red light.
>>Narrator: Still harboring dreams
of becoming the world's most
senior astronaut, Campbell delights
in taking her students on mock
missions using high-tech tools...
>>Sharon: Oh, my goodness.
It's a spaceship.
>>Narrator: ...and low-tech gimmicks
to keep her students
engaged in the experience.
>>Sharon: You know, our 21st-century
students are very different
than the students I had 20 years ago.
Our kids have been taught to learn
by looking at a television screen.
That's where their attention goes.
And I'll tell you,
without technology,
I couldn't reach the students.
>>There is some oxygen on Mars.
There is an iron core, and the
entire surface is rust-covered.
>>Sharon: If I can create something
that makes them curious,
I've got 'em.
>>Ladies and gentlemen, we
are having an asteroid storm.
>>Narrator: While hiding from
asteroids, students discover
and describe the artifacts
they find under their desks.
>>Sharon: I would like each of you
to estimate the temperature
inside your cave.
>>Narrator: For the teacher,
it's a carefully crafted
interdisciplinary lesson.
For students, it's learning
that's natural and fun.
>>Sharon: Make sure that your
measurements are accurate.
>>The students understand
that what you learn
in your math class has
applications in your science class,
and what you learn in your science
class definitely has applications
in your art class, your language
class, your mathematics class,
and I have the time to make
those kinds of tie-ins.
So I've been given a gift
by the school district
to be able to do this.
>>Sharon: Satellite
One, Satellite One.
Ladies and gentlemen, we
have a window of opportunity.
All clear, all clear.
Everyone come back.
Watch your eyes.
Okay.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to Edutopia.org.